大家好,我是七八七五毛。
上一节课的话就跟大家交流分享了日内交易的三分钟模型。
那么这一次的话就跟大家讲一讲这个五分钟的日内交易模型。
那么其实五分钟的日内交易模型的交易的一个逻辑跟核心呢,
其实就是我们五分钟短线交易系统的一个缩小板。
也就是说我们五分钟短线交易系统里面呢,它可能是一个波段存在这个隔夜的情况。
那么日内交易呢只是将这个五分钟的这个波段在这个日内这一部分提显的兑现出来。
那么这就是我们五分钟这个短线交易系统。
那么我们五分钟模型呢,它主要的一个交易议记呢,就是刚说的,
就是跟我们之前介绍了这个五分钟短线交易系统的这个买卖点的入场议记基本上是一致的。
但是呢,因为它是日内,所以经常会使用这个二十斤线,就是我们这个出场的这个主要的平常一句。
那么之所以要跟大家介绍这个五分钟的这个交易模型,目的呢就三个。
第一个呢,就是希望能够控制这个日内的一个交易频率。
因为其实五分钟的这个模型啊,在日内里面呢,可能就只交易一次或者两次啊,
所以它的交易频率呢基本上是很少的。
而当时呢,因为需要是少,当时呢,它可以获得这个收益空间也会比较大,
那么这个就是我们第二个的目的。
那么第三个的目的呢,其实就是说我们这个日内模型呢,它是基于这个波段里面的日内交易的机会。
虽然呢,它会有一种看长但是做短的一个一个一个一个一个体现。
那么所以说我们做这个五分钟模型的日内交易呢,其实呢,
呃,更加看重的就是这个120或者是250均线啊,这个买卖点的一个提示的一个机会。
所以基本上就是说你按照这个入场点去入啊,那么可能你一天就会只交易一次。
那么你一次的这个收益呢,可能会比较可观啊,无论你这个收益到底有多大,
但是在这个交易日啊,收盘钱,那么一定是要平餐的,一定是要平餐的。
也就是说在这个下午的三点钟之前,呃,或者是晚上的十一点钟之前,那一定是要平上今天平餐的。
呃,那么其实在这个五分钟这个模型里面呢,呃,如果你是想将这个波段在进一步的话分这些小的波段的话,
操作时度呢,也可以按照这个三分钟模型操作的机会。
也就是说在这个五分钟模型里面呢,也可以按照这个,呃,去做这个二十二十均线啊,
上穿啊,上穿那么你去做多或者下坡你去做空啊,这种方式去操作。
但是因为五分钟里面呢,一个K线,它的K线相对的三分钟呢,就没有那么呃,灵敏。
那敏感性肯定也不够,所以同样的一个幅度啊,在五分钟里面呢,可能看起来就很短。
呃,那么三分钟,三分钟看起来的这个幅度就比较大。
那么这样子的话,给我们在这个交易的时候呢,这个世界上呢,可能会更加好,好,好,判断一点点。
至少对于我们的盘感来讲呢,它是一个呃,它,它对于点位的把望呢,可能会更加好一点点。
毕竟自内的话,有时候行情波动快的话,你用五分钟很容易就打直损,或者是很容易来不及去直损,那么造成你这个规循会比较大的情况。
所以呢,就是说呃,具体的话,呃,尽可能的哈,尽可能的按照这个五分钟短线交易系统的模型去做这个五分钟的这个日内交易。
呃,那么如果是说你确实是想按照三分钟,那么你就要考虑第一点,就是跟三分钟的交易模型,
三分钟的交易模型里面的提示的点一样,你一定要注意这个这个空间的大小,呃,一定要去注意这个出入场点的这个及时的执行。
那么这是避免你在这个五分钟的运用的时候呢,会出现太大的这种呃,不必要的这个损失。
但是呢,我给大家做介绍这个五分钟呢,啊,目的呢,就是让大家能够尽量的控制这个交易的这个频率,
因为呃,很多粉丝也知道哈,就是我们交易的频率越多啊,那么我们出的机会越大。
那么如果出了机会越多呢,那么可能你对于你当天的这个交易的心态呢,就会产生比较大的影响。
啊,这个后果呢,可能会不断的产生这个恶性循环,那么对于你整个的交易的话,可能都不会有它理想的一个结果。
所以说,啊,控制频率呢,其实也是对于你心态,啊,交易心理的一种,啊,比较好的一个提升,啊,比较好的提升。
那么我们也可以来看一下这个具体的一个行情的一个情况。
呃,那么拿今天这个,拿今天的这个,本影戏来讲吧,哈,因为最近的话,最近这一周的话,一直是跟这些,呃,跟我们这个群里面的,呃,粉丝们一直就是交流,就是这个本影戏啊,
呃,关注这个回产250均线的这个机会去做,那么这时候呢,呃,我们250均线呢,我们的一个交易呢,基本上就是说我在250均线进入,那么一直拿,拿到这个,如果是说他吓破了这个120均线呢,
那我们可能就会考虑出场,那这是我们做这个波段短线,短线波段交易的,呃,那如果我做日内呢,那么可能我这一点进,那么在收盘之前呢,也就是在这个,
这个,这个,这个收盘之前,也就是大概在7000,呃,收盘在大概在7000之前,7000这个位置上,那么无论我们后面是怎么走,那么我们在这个收盘之前,一定是要做这个指引处理的,一定要做这个指引处理,啊,
所以就是说你收盘前一定是要出来的,呃,同样的我们再看一看我的在区里面推荐的另外一个品种这个东丽梅,呃,东丽梅的话,最近也是走的比较,走的比较漂亮啊,这个日线走的比较漂亮,那么在5分钟的级别里面呢,他基本上是研制啊多,基本上后面几次呢,就是都是研制这个120均线啊,回产120均线时候就往上走,呃,那么像今天一样的,
就是说如果我在这个今天早上开盘进入了,那么进入之后呢,在收盘之前呢,那可能收盘之前呢,他是
跌破了这个20均线,呃,那么跌破20均线的这个就就就就就好说哈,因为我们本来做之内呢,就是以20均线作为我们这个平常在这个考虑的这个主要余计,那么这个跌破的话,你自然就出来,那假如是收盘是收盘在这个612点6哈,
假如是收盘的这些最高价,那这个时候呢,收盘的在这一个,那么你肯定是在你收盘之前呢,啊,你肯定是要出来,无论后面是涨,涨多或涨多少啊,然后这个后面,我们今天晚上看的好像是跌,对吧,
那没事,反正我们日内的话,就是一定是在你收盘之前,一定是要出来,一定是要出来,呃,这就是我们做这个日内的这个,呃,一样的,那么我们再来看一下做空的哈,就比如这个做空的,
那么今天这个相较呢,我是在这个,呃,这个155,基本上就是说他向上回彩这个120均线的时候,那么没有突破,然后呢往下彩,
那我是在15825的位置上做空的,那么做空的他一直我就一直拿到这个这个这个,呃,拿到了一个15315这一刻,
就是回,呃,就在上,就是,呃,这是在收盘,收盘价,是基本上是收盘在最低,呃,算是
有一点小贩他吧,大概就是这个位置上啊,那么我不管后面是怎么走,那我这个空单呢,我做日内的我这个空单就收盘之前我就出来了,
所以说这个,那么这一半的话,就从八,你就是从八百到这个三百,那你要五百点,那么也一手也有五千块钱的这个收益了,
所以呢,基本上你一天呢,就做一单啊,一天可能就做一波啊,基本上从早上就拿到下午,收盘钱,那就做一半一波,那就就五分钟模型
所以呢,就是说你在收盘之前呢,你就肯定出来你是做日内的模型,那么如果你是做这个
叫,呃,波段的,波段的呢
那么可能你就会沿着这条线一直就去拿着,只要他不
不会上坡这个120斤,现在那你可能就一直的拿着这个空单啊,一直到这个下坡的这个限量,你可能才会出来
才会出来,但是呢,就是说,呃,你搞不好呢,就怎么说呢,就是有时候呢,我们做波段的呢
主要是说他会下坡,那么你打个比方,你是在这个位置做空的,那我做波段的话呢,可能他这个线到下面的时候呢,这个就突破了,那么你这个空间,引力的空间
啊,就稍微就会变窄了,但是我们今天当天的利润呢,就这么多啊,我就拿到了基本上这么多的一个
一个利润,这就是这个做日内的好处啊,后面的行情怎么样,那么基本上我就是因为把我能够转到了这部分的利润,我就先锁定了
啊,这就是做日内的好处
所以说,呃,我们介绍这个五分钟的模型呢,啊,就是目的就
刚才说了就很简单,就是帮大家去控制我们的这个交易频率啊,增加这个盈亏比
盈亏比啊,那么这个就是我们五分钟交易的模型,因为这个模型呢,就是这个五分钟短线,短线波段交易的这个系统的这个
日内版日内版,就是缩效版了,所以呢,这个交易的逻辑呢,还有操作的这个
买卖点的依据呢,基本上都是差不多的,所有的基本上就是这个模型呢,我就不再
在在在相细的去做这个深入的分析,呃,那么
呃,这些看到话就大概的分享的内容就到这里结束,呃,还是那句话,就是如果有这个盘中的机会的话啊,那么我会录制一段这个
三分钟的这个示范交易的这个视频啊,那么具体是什么时候呢,这个可能就不好说,根据我这一边的这个时间安排的话
到时候如果有的话我会尽快的放上来,那么如果大家对这一块感兴趣的话,可以继续关注